what it was for me is when i'd feel this
moment of anxiety and i remember in 2014
i was in shanghai china with my daughter
and i woke up one morning and i was like
oh gosh you know this company that i'd
founded that became a unicorn like very
quickly within two years it was on a run
rate of 200 million dollars in sales
what was the company uh the company was
called alfion it's now the second
largest
uh healthcare lender in the united
states oh wow wow and and so
i remember thinking though i needed to
raise money at that time and i was like
we're going to take the company public
and i have to do a series a and the
series b and all the other stuff wait
you got to be a unicorn company before
you even raise a series a or b yeah well
actually the series a the series a i
knew i was going into it our we did a a
very large seed round and the seed round
was about 250 million dollars oh my god
oh my god that's insignificant and then
we did a our series a was 700 million
pre-money and our series b was one point
uh 1.1 billion
yeah well isn't a unicorn a billion
dollar company billion dollars yeah so i
was but the series a and the series b
happened within you know only less than
a year of each other so it was all
around the same time and i knew it was
coming up and we were going to take the
company public and i needed to
get
you know kind of like a series a and
series be done even though we didn't
really need the capital
we needed the validation so that we
could get to the public markets but then
ultimately we didn't get to go to the
public market because uh the market
basically collapsed during 2016 there
were no ipos done
and so i went through like a really
difficult time as a result of that but
that's a whole other part of the story
but what i was doing when i was in
shanghai is i was knowing that i was
facing this thing and i didn't like the
idea of having to go get venture capital
money just to get the validation
right on valuation the company was
growing leaps and bounds very successful
we went from zero to a thousand
employees in 18 months like it was it
was crazy all over the world
and
what happened was i woke up and i said
to my daughter i'm like sweetheart we're
gonna go
to the bulgari store
bulgari
and we're gonna buy a watch and she's
like why are we gonna buy a watch and i
said she's like 18 years old at the time
and i said well because i have to
collapse the wave function
and she's like what the heck does that
mean dad and i said well
what it is is
whenever i feel this anxiety and i have
this big challenge coming up
most people would sort of like go for
the idea of if i achieve something i'm
going to give myself the reward
right and so i decided to put the card
in front of the horse
and give myself the reward because i
understood that embodying
and being the thing i wanted to achieve
was tantamount to actually achieving it
right so i would buy watches because how
many times you look at your watch a day
that was the only reason why i would do
it and i would buy this really expensive
watch that i'd been kind of like
aspiring to have and everything when i
was still stuck in my material world
type of thing and i would buy this watch
so i bought this really nice watch and
it was a a reward for having overcome in
the future
the thing i hadn't achieved yet damn
and it was a burn the ship's mentality
you've heard this story about uh you
know cortez going to mexico with
terrible conquistador type activity but
what he did that was kind of crazy
genius uh i'm not putting any morals
behind what he actually did to like you
know take over the nation or take over
the land from the indigenous peoples but
what he did that was kind of crazy was
he had 300 men and i think it was six
ships and they're in this bay and they
all went to kind of go to the bathroom
and they come back out onto the beach
and they look and they see all their
ships on fire and they're like how do
all our ships get on fire and cortez
looks like he says
well there won't be any other ships
coming from spain for another year
there's 300 of us and there's three
million of them
and we have to survive this i burn the
ships
there's no going back
oh god he like it was a forced
he forced the situation he forced the
situation he's like we're here to
conquer and to win
and to a certain extent you know that
was probably the stage of my life when i
was like very much in that
material mode of you know winning and
and succeeding and all of that and i
thought okay i'll buy a watch i'll
collapse the wave function every time i
look at my watch i'm gonna remember the
thing that i've already achieved
as if it had already happened yeah
and i found it was very successful
and i could do that i could collapse a
wave function but that was the earlier
stage and i didn't really that's the
time that i still believe that
i could make things happen in the world
and now i realize you know having gone
through my own spiritual path is that
yes that was sort of like me playing
with myself in what's called lila
and leela is this notion of maya
or samsara
which is
you are playing with yourself to make
you believe in a way
that it was you all along that came up
with this and
you know there wasn't a such thing in my
world as destiny i believed in free will
it was all about free will you know you
make it happen you know there are three
types of people i used to say this all
the time three types of people in the
world
people that like some people make things
happen
some people watch things happen and
other people wonder what the hell just
happened
and and i would definitely be in the
mindset of a make it happen kind of
person probably like yourself i would
bet yeah i was gonna say that i agree
with that yeah and and so i i really
discounted any optionality or any
notion that there could be a destiny
involved
and that maybe
what i call destiny i later learned
might actually just be the free will of
the higher self
is this operating separately from us
well not separately it's it's working
through us but it is the first stop
what is that part that observer you
talked about the observer at first and
you know i have kind of
been been in those spaces before where
i've been been able to be the observer
and in fact more and more in my life
just walking through life becoming more
of the observer of things instead of
feeling things so personally it's just
things happening
um but what what is what is it that
you're explaining then with this
observer with this sort of
higher self i just got done having a
discussion with aubry marcus
and you know i'm i'm in austin right now
and i was just with aubry and we're
talking about hermeticism and the first
principle
of the seven principles of her medicine
there you go i read it i grabbed it
because i was like i had heard that you
had about her medicism listening to
stuff before i talked to you and i was
like i read this book this is fantastic
it's a vibe it's definitely a vibe and
actually that's the third law or the
third principle of hermeticism is
vibration law of vibration but
the very first principle and each of
these principles tied to the chakras
right we're born the root is born into
this world where we're conditioned to
believe that's like the construct of
this world is is conditioned to make you
believe in a way that everything is
about material it's solid you can count
on this thing right you're born in this
world of separation and you know you
have this separation and then fear
creeps in and all the other aspects that
then we decide what are the things that
bring us shame and those are the things
i don't want to be
and the things that don't bring us shame
are the things that i want to ascribe to
i want to show the world that i am that
thing and then as we get older we start
to want to align more and more with that
perfection
and not see the other aspects of
ourselves that we repress entirely
yeah the shadow self shadow the negative
aspects of ourselves
and so you know this whole idea of
mentalism is the first principle of
hermeticism
is to basically break down this
conditioned idea that by the way i
believe we all subjected ourselves to
you know think of ourselves as more in a
construct of matrix of mind
where you're in an avatar
and this avatar body right imagine that
we're making let's say you and i decided
to make a video game and the video game
was here
and it was intended to teach human
awareness and consciousness
how to expand so you'd probably come up
with some rules right and there would be
like some ground rules yeah
some you know principles that are gonna
always be lasting constance if you will
right across that game environment yeah
we want people to learn through
experience not by didactic learning we
want people to have the experience of
what it's like and the more real you
make it
the more powerful the learnings can be
yeah so you put yourself into a
situation where
you don't remember any of it
oh it's a hot stove i mean you can say
don't touch the hat so but sometimes you
gotta touch the hot stove that's right
and you don't remember that you actually
chose all this that's part of the game
and the whole game is intended for you
to refine yourself and remember who you
are
and so as you go through this game
you're you're learning all these aspects
of yourself you start taking on you know
i have to learn how to transcend this
notion of duality and
it's not always about black and white
here's what's right and what's wrong
maybe
the objective truth is that it's the sum
of all possible perspectives
and maybe i can start learning to see
outside of the perspectives that i had
been conditioned into
and maybe those conditionings are more
predestined
in the context of when i was born in the
time i was born into and astrology and
neurology and all the other stuff
and what you're describing now is a game
that's more like a matrix of mind